In the shadows of the screen where the
poet's unseen dagger flows like a stream automated
on our dream.
Beds and bites align,
stress in this
digital
land.
Dagger testing every
Open your mess and takes the stage marks
vision in the cage, identity
to engage Kubernetes
in the rage. Multitenants find their place in
this coded space,
managing with grace, open your ness, and sets
the pace.
Alright. Let's try this attempt number.
Mark's probably been keeping count, raging at me.
26,
I think.
I'm
not sure what's happened. The streaming software that
I use will not let me go to
the prescheduled event, which is very frustrating. I
tried everything that I could, even hooking up
custom RTMP.
That event just is not working. So apologies,
everyone. Thank you for your patience.
But I'm your host, David Flanagan. This is
an episode of Rawkode live where we take
a look
at really cool open source software and the
cloud native ecosystem.
And today, we are continuing our mission to
Daggerize open source projects.
And today, I'm gonna be joined by Mark
Bernstein, and we're going to Daggerize
his open source project, OpenUnison.
Hey, Mark. How are you? I mean, you're
talking Good. How are doing? Now. Right?
Alright.
Let's dive straight into it and not keep
people waiting anymore.
Yeah. Let's do it. TLDR. Who are you?
What you've been up to, and what is
OpenUnison,
please?
So Mark Borschtien, CTO at Terminal Security.
I'm the author of OpenUnison.
OpenUnison does authentication,
authorization,
deep space as a service.
Might know me from
talking about Kubernetes or helping people out in
Slack.
I am also the coauthor of Kubernetes,
an enterprise guide, first and second edition, the
third edition next month. So keep an eye
on Amazon.
Great stuff. GitLab,
OPA, Gatekeeper,
OpenSearch,
you know, Vault,
vCluster,
Pulumi.
It's
it it it it it's a big update.
So even if you read one of the
previous updates,
you're gonna want this one too. So, yeah,
all in it. And after today's session, you're
gonna be adding the Dagger chapter. Right?
I my publishers will murder me in my
sleep if I try to add any more
to this book, so then we'll hold that
one till the fourth edition.
Alright. No problem.
Okay. So today's mission is we're gonna take
your project OpenUnison,
which is a Kubernetes native identity
management multitenancy
kind of bits and pieces
software. It's written in Java. It's very cool.
We've done a whole session on this before.
Feel free to go to Rawkode.live
and just search for OpenUnison and you will
find that demo. Today,
what we're gonna do is just Dagger to
provision an ephemeral Kubernetes
cluster.
We're going to deploy OpenUnison to it with
its Helm chart,
and then we're gonna start
modifying some of those values in the Helm
chart, which modifies the deployment in some way,
and we're gonna run
tests against it. We're gonna build assertions all
inside of our Dagger pipeline, something that I
feel you will find infinitely valuable, I hope,
with your project and testing it, and we're
gonna show everyone how to do it live
as they're nowhere twenty two minutes in, and
we've been talking for less than three. So
I'm so stressed. I know. I'm excited because
I've never
like, I conceptually
know what Dagger is,
but I've never used it. So this is
gonna be a lot of fun for me.
I get to learn something.
Awesome. Well, I am happy to be your
muse and guide for today, which is now
the third time I've said that. So, anyway
and if you didn't hear all of that
custom song at the start, I'm gonna upload
them later. Mark has now heard it 14
times.
So
here's my screen.
I have the OpenUnison website here. So if
people wanna learn more, you can check out
OpenUnison.GitHub.io.
It also has everything that we need to
understand how to deploy it, although I do
have you. So we're probably not gonna need
to docs that much. Right?
You
know,
I'm I'm here so you can ridicule how
bad the documentation is.
That is not today's mission. Don't you worry.
What else do we have here? We have
the terminal security
OpenUnison
repository. So if you wanna contribute to the
code, everything is here and open source. That
is Java, I warn you. And that's the
only Java pop I'm gonna take today. I
promise.
I'll take it right on the right on
the chest. You you you can try and
land those body blows against Java. I'll take
those all day. I've gotta be honest. I
mean, Java these days is much better in
container based applications. Like, the first like, if
you went back five years, I'd say don't
do it ever. I think now it's
it's a lot easier.
Yeah.
Maybe.
We can get into that later. We
also have the Dagger first here. We're gonna
go some preexisting modules for today's. We're not
gonna reinvent the wheel like we did in
the last session.
And we also have the Dagger documentation should
we need it. So we are all set.
We are all prepped, and we are good
to start building some Dagger
code.
So here's my terminal. I've already cloned the
OpenUnison repository,
and
we are gonna create a new Dagger
module.
Is
that transparency really annoying?
No. I'm not sure why you're starting it
in the OpenUnison.
Is that not where the Helm chart is?
No. So No. The actual Helm charts
are
GitHub.com/OpenUnison/helmcharts.
Do I have the right yes. So here
are the Helm charts.
And I lost you. Where'd you go?
Don't leave me.
Here we go. Private chat.
I'm gonna send that to you. Yeah. So
we
we broke up the Helm chart. So we
have customers that run on Kubernetes. We also
have lot of customers that run-in
kind of a typical legacy
VM IT infrastructure.
So we decided to
break it up a little bit.
So what you were
the the actual OpenUnison
GitHub repo has the source code for how
OpenUnison works.
Like, it's that base platform,
but the Helm charts are how everything gets
deployed.
I'm gonna remove that,
opacity because it's gonna
I mean, it works for me, but I'm
worried that it's just gonna look absolutely dreadful,
for everyone. Oh, you mean on the, terminal?
Yeah.
Yeah. It's a little distracting.
Thought I thought it was pretty cool because
I could see the documentation behind it, but
with all the text, it's
it's it's a little distracting.
There we go.
Okay.
So we have the helm charts.
Yeah. This is the Helm charts. So which
what are we deploying
first? Where are we where are we deploying?
So
the way that we like to deploy
so OpenUnison,
when you deploy OpenUnison,
standard,
like, I'm scaling up a new cluster, wanna
deploy it. We have an executable
called OU control.
That's really just three Helm charts and a
trench coat.
The
problem with using that that
binary is that now you have to import
that binary. Right? And so if you're using
a CICD system or, you know, some kind
of automation system, you want something that's a
little more native, and Helm is native to
everything. Right?
So
there are
four charts I think we need to deploy
with a
in in this mechanism.
Mhmm. And the reason why I say there
are four charts so the first chart you
deploy is OpenUnison operator.
That includes all the CRDs that we use,
the operator,
and really that base platform.
Then
we deploy,
excuse me, Orchestra.
And so that actually deploys OpenUnison.
So think of that as your platform. That's
you know, OpenUnison
is
kind of a blank slate for identity based
applications.
You create your application
by assembling a bunch of CRDs in YAML.
That's what Orchestra login portal is. So when
you go to log in to your cluster
and you see the badge for the the
dashboard and you see the badge for your
token and any other applications that you integrate,
that's coming from the orchestra login portal chart.
Finally,
since we're using k threes and it's a
managed cluster, if you're gonna actually SSO
into the cluster, which ultimately, that's what OpenUnison
is for, you're then gonna deploy
the Orchestra Kubo IDC proxy.
The good thing is this all uses one
YAML file. It's just the the reason why
we break it up is to make it
a little easier to manage. And then especially
with integration systems,
because there's a lot going on
with Helm, you can tell Helm, hey. Wait
for the pods to finish.
Wait for all the jobs to finish.
And in the OU control binary,
we kinda cheat a little because we don't
wait for all the pods to finish before
we move on to the next one because
we know when we're at a point to
move on.
But any kind of IAC
tool,
that doesn't really work super well.
So we added a couple of flags to
be able to say, okay. We're gonna make
sure
that
we're not gonna be done with this help
chart until everything is rolled out. So that
way, the IAC tools have something to key
off of.
Okay.
So let's just start making some progress on
this. I think there's value to both routes
here. Let's start with deploying with the Helm
route. But, you know, using all your control,
I don't think it's gonna be that difficult
either, so we can also do that. But
first, we have to create a new Dagger
module. Now I'm not gonna use Go today.
I thought I was using that earlier.
I'm gonna stick with TypeScript just because it's
what I'm more comfortable with. And when I
watched the last one, see me fighting with
Python. Let's not fight with Python today.
Fighting with snakes is bad. Yeah.
I couldn't even format the code properly. It
was awful.
Alright. So let's get this.
And I'm just gonna go check if we
have a helm
here.
We do.
Oh, we can actually use this module for
Helm. And I know there's actually there's a
lot, but this one does have a partner
logo. So
that to me says, trust it.
And I'm gonna copy that installation.
So I'll give you the bit of the
TLDR on what Dagger is as well just
since you're not that familiar.
It is an as code tool,
for doing CICD style workflows. Essentially,
built a DAG of commands that you wanna
run. All runs inside of containers, super cacheable,
very robust,
and
a joy and a pleasure to work with.
When we initialize a new Dagger project,
because this is TypeScript,
we're gonna get a Dagger JSON here that
just says this is where the Dagger code
lives and it's still using the TypeScript SDK.
And then inside of here, we have
oh, let's call it Helm charts just because
of the directory that we're in, but we
now have two functions.
These functions are written in TypeScript, obviously.
And if we come over here, we can
do Dagger
functions list,
and it'll tell us what functions we have
available, and we can execute one. Now looking
at the code here,
these are just wrapped in a annotation property
on TypeScript that says, okay. This is something
we want to expose as a function. It
grabs a container image and runs a command.
This one mounts a directory, sets a working
directory, and runs a graph across it as
well. So
nice fluent interface
makes building all of these different functions and
pipelines super simple.
And
why did I get a no?
I'm just being deaf, aren't I?
There we go. Trusted my history, and I
shouldn't have. So now we've got these two
functions, and we can do a Dagger call,
container
echo. Now this is going to run the
function. So what we expect to see here
is that it pulls Alpine, executes echo, and
it has a string argument
called string arc. So the first one is
gonna fail and tell us that we need
string
arc,
and I'll just say hi,
Mark.
All good? Is that making sense to you?
Where's the container running? Like, is this running
against the Kubernetes cluster? Is this running locally
against your Docker
daemon?
It's running locally against my Podman.
So what actually happens is that Dagger spins
up a BuildKit process with an API, and
we're communicating well with that BuildKit process, and
then it is running other BuildKit layers and
stuff in the behind the scenes.
Very cool. So
yeah. It is very, very cool.
So that's the quick baptism by fire there
for understanding what we want to do. Now
we need helm.
So we could
just say,
you know, if I'm pretty sure that as
a Helm container image,
or we could do, Ubuntu
20 o four where we run
an apt update, apt install Helm. But Helm
is actually a bit more convoluted because,
unfortunately, it requires adding the official Kubernetes
repository. It's not part of Ubuntu's native packaging.
So we're not gonna do that. And instead,
we're gonna just do a Dagger install
from the So
riddle me this.
I have a container
that has Helm and OU control in it.
Is it just easier to use that?
We could do it both ways. I think
we're gonna have time to to experiment and
have a bit of fun.
Okay. But because we're installing this module right
now,
we might as well just take a look
at what this is actually doing. So Okay.
We can come to s I go module.
This is the other really cool thing about
Dagger, right, is that all these modules can
be written in any of the supported SDKs,
whether that be Go, TypeScript, Python.
They just become available. There's Alexa. There's Rust.
It's really cool how quickly that's all coming
together. But now I know why you like
it so much. It's got
It's got Rust support. I know. So
here, we can see that this Helm one
exposes a whole bunch of different functions. So
we've got like a version, we've a package
push,
and we've got a test. So actually, I
don't think this module really does what we
want it to do because it doesn't allow
us to just execute Helm commands. It seems
to be more
of a publishing Helm
Yeah. Charts.
So
maybe I should have read the docs on
it. So let's see what else we have.
Here are the Helm one, but we could
just use your image as well.
Yeah. Okay. That one would probably work. What's
your image called?
Let me grab it for you.
And while we're doing that, I'll just show
what did happen here. So we go to
the terminal.
We've added this function.
Dagger
does code gen behind the scenes,
meaning
that when we go enter our function here,
we can do dag dot helm dot,
and
we can see that package push stuff here.
And we're getting code complete
the entire time. It's telling us exactly what
we want to do, and we can click
into it and see that this takes a
directory, a registry, and so forth. So all
of this happens regardless of language. Dagger generates
an SDK.
So developing with it is working with a
really strongly typed,
nice API,
and I love that too. So
right. You got an image for me?
Yeah. I'm just making sure I give you
the right one.
Yeah. Don't set me up for failure, please.
Come on. Yeah.
Here.
So I'm just gonna prepare
for our first deploy step.
We'll call this deploy
OpenUnison.
Okay. Let's go with this one. I don't
think I've merged this in yet,
but let me do that. Returns a container.
Where's chat?
Alright. So here's the image, and this image
has
it says vCluster because we use the we
originally built this
as part of our vCluster onboarding process, but
it includes vCluster,
helm, coop control,
and
OU control. So,
you know, all we really need to do
to make this work is mount
a values file
and the couple of secrets we need and
our control configuration.
Okay. Awesome.
So what I'm gonna show you here is
that, first, I changed the docs on this
function.
I took away all the parameters.
I'm returning a container,
that'll become important shortly.
I'm now using your image, which hopefully isn't
too large,
and then I'm gonna execute Helm version.
And, actually, I think Helm might just be
Helm version rather than Dash. I think you're
right. Yeah.
So now we can come back here and
run Dagger functions, and we'll see how those
small tweaks
to the code change what we get back
from this Dagger functions call.
Marco's saying he's already tried your image, and
it works. Awesome. Thanks, man. Sweet.
Now we're just waiting for it to pull.
Hopefully,
it's not too big. I hope you're not
shipping it. It's so big? Sexy egg images.
No. There we go.
Alright. So we've got our function called deployed
open deploy OpenUnison
with my documentation,
which is obviously not that great, but it
does come from here. Great doc. Hey. It's
more documentation than I usually write.
Now we can call deploy open
Unison.
Now let's remember that this returns a container.
Right? So if I run this,
we're gonna get output,
but we're not really gonna be able to
understand it that well. It's gonna be swallowed
up because we haven't really requested anything back.
So let's just give that a wee second
to run.
Now is this pulling the container every time,
or has it got a
caching? I I haven't used Podman in
couple of years. So it's it's it's now
actually pulling the container because when I ran
Dagger functions, it was really just regenerating that
SDK to list the functions for us. So
now it's actually pulling that container, so it
won't take too long.
But, yeah, they're they're all cashed. They're gonna
be over the air. They're pills at once.
Yeah.
I was gonna say we'll do something else,
but it's already finished. So as you can
see, like, it's done stuff, but we don't
have any idea what that stuff is. So
we can then start to dive into that
container. Now there's two routes here when working
with Dagger. I could then modify this and
say, give me standard out and change this
to be a string, and then we'd see
that output on the command line.
But
if even if you don't wanna go change
in the API surface too much and just
say, you know, I'm happy with a container,
we can actually just use the CLI and
say, okay. Get me the standard out for
that container run.
And there we go. We've now got Helm
version three fifteen point three coming from your
thing.
In the same vein That's cool. Modify
this. And you said it was all your
control. Let's see if it's got a very
thin command.
It doesn't. I don't actually think it does,
but you'll see an error. Right?
Yeah. I'll see something.
Marco is trying to get me to reveal
some cool things of the the Dagger workflow
here. So you see this this I'm pointing
to my monitor. Right? The bottom line, I'm
gonna run it again, but we can actually
ask it to zoom in and show us
more details by using the plus and minus
commands.
And and you can just add all keys
to jump between these, like, parallel tasks and
a whole bunch of other stuff.
Yeah. Very, very cool CLI.
Alright. We actually got OU control as not
a file or directory.
I wonder if it's just not in the
path. Let's
let me look at something here real quick.
Now we also need a Kubernetes cluster. So
while you do that, I'm gonna come here
and search for k three s. And Marcos,
who's in the chat, has this community module,
not a partner, Marcos. You need to get
your your your label in.
We'll go to installation
and we'll add this module.
Now we also get
blue examples
so we can click on oh, there's no
TypeScript, but I'll wing it. We've got a
go one here
where we can just kinda see this is
roughly how we need this to work.
Even though it's go, I am
going to copy it,
drop it in here just as a reference.
So now I can do async
ephemeral
k three s cluster.
It's gonna return a promise,
and I'm gonna return a service.
Oh,
that's why.
Okay.
I got it installed as a KubeControl plug
in.
You got it as a plug in, so
it's KubeControl or your control.
Yeah.
That's alright.
Let's just confirm before we go any further,
though. Right? So cube control,
all your CTL.
Just to help, Let's see what we get.
Go back to my code.
So now
this temporary cluster, less service, this function that
provides the Kubernetes service that we need. What
we want to do is get Dagger,
k three s.
What's the name? Okay. We'll just call it
It takes options.
Oh, we can even provide our own image.
That's that's
cool, we think.
And what we want to do from the
example here is
get ourselves a server
and
start it.
So what is server returning?
A service. Okay. We are happy with just
that, to be honest. Let's return
await
service.
Is it
import?
Sweet.
So let's see what our output says.
No. Keep control. Oh, you control then.
Oh, I spelled it wrong. Out control.
I'm trying my best. I'm trying my best.
How do you know it's a livestream?
It's not scripted. Stuff doesn't work.
SciFi Geeks universe saying that that is the
most installed module. Yeah. I can imagine it's
a pretty popular module. Definitely.
So this gonna run case Kubernetes the line.
It's a own container
inside of your pod?
Yeah. Your old control is not working, but
I'm not fussed. We had Helm. Right? And
that's what's important for me. Sorry. Can tell
me what's that question again?
So OU Control is
or I'm sorry. So Kind is running in
a container inside of your Podman. Is that
how that's gonna get launched?
I don't think it's actually running as a
container, but we can run Podman alias to
see,
because it's all orchestrated by BuildKit. I don't
think it's ever exposed to, like, your Docker
containers list or your Podman containers list. It
doesn't it's not something. But I'll check. I've
never actually done that before. Yeah. Curious.
Alright. So we need Helm.
We know that version works.
Let's leave it at that. But what we
need now is to run that Helm against
a cluster.
So we're going to see
this dot ephemeral cluster, which gives us our
service,
and
we can
start that.
And just call this const k three s
equals
faxing my code.
Start does not exist.
Response awaited.
And now we have a promise service,
which is fine.
SciFi geeks are saying we need a verified
flag.
Little blue checkbox or we circle. That's what
we need of. Alright.
So going back to this Go example, once
we've started it, we could check for errors,
but that's more just a Go thing. And
we wanna get the endpoint so that we
can actually connect our Helm cluster up to
it. So
we can say endpoint
equals k three guess
Endpoint. And then we can provide the port
and stuff that we need.
So I'm just leaning into this Go example
that Marcos has already done,
which is port 80
on scheme HTTP.
And this should go to us. Is this
endpoint
for
the API server that k three is running
on?
Like, what what's that Yes. Yeah. It's it's
a we can
we can point our helm to this endpoint
and
run Interesting.
Don't even know if you could use k
threes with port 80.
Sorry? You didn't know?
I I didn't know that k three supported
because I didn't think the API server
supported unencrypted connections anymore.
Yeah. We may have to pull out the
KubeConfig,
actually,
but we'll get there.
Now
what we need to do here is say
web service binding.
So we're going to connect it to our
service,
which we called k three s. I'm assuming
that's what this parameter here was, was the
service name
as
so
web service binding.
Yep. We've got the alias.
No. In fact, we don't need anything more.
Once the service oh, okay. Yeah. It's a
local alias.
I'm being very silly.
Oh, we want this.
And that's a promise.
There we go.
I bet you Marcos is just yelling at
me right now.
Oh, nice. Okay. So Marcos is actually exposing
this. This is cool facts. I'm glad he's
here. The port 80 is to access an
NGINX deployment in the example, not the API
server. The API server gets access to via
the KubeConfig.
So
Gotcha. Okay. That makes sense. So so the
k threes has a embedded
NGINX
in it.
Cool. Well,
that's good because we're gonna need that.
Yes.
So let's remove our Go code.
Well, let's just make sure this works.
And we're not using our endpoint yet. Let's
just comment it out. But make sure it's
service binding and the service starts.
So
let's do a call.
Marcos is telling me to use the documentation.
Just got to point to RTFM.
Yeah. Funnily enough, you know that
the original name of Rawkode Live was RTFM,
so way
back in 2039.
So, yeah, long time ago. The dark times.
Yes.
So this is let's I know this is
gold code, but, you know, best example, in
fact, we'll look at it with the the
highlight in the right here.
So he is pulling Alpine Helm, which we
could have done too. However, we have now
pulled your code.
And he's saying set KubeConfig to here and
then he's mounting it. So the k three
s module exposes this config, and we could
have just clicked on the functions here to
see that too, which we can then mount,
and then we can just run our commands.
So, like, this is the easiest k three
s and say the container for Dagger I
have ever seen in my life. So
that is a testament to Marcos' work.
Mhmm.
So
we
can do
oh, so that's interesting, Marcos. I'm glad you're
in the chat. Right? Because
I'm doing a service binding,
but because you've got the Kube config, is
it even do I even need to look
at the service binding?
Because I'm assuming maybe not.
So but we do need a web file.
We need to then store.
And what was your path? You just stuck
it in KubeConfig.
Yeah.
I mean, I could just throw this in
temp. It's actually not that important, and we'll
call this KubeConfig.
And the file that we're mounting is the
conf oh, multiple cursors there. That's weird.
And we're using
k three s. So now I'm I'm pulling
out too many objects here, so I'm gonna
have to return
let me refactor my code.
Just return our k three s,
which is
k three s client. Is that the one
that has the config? Yes. Okay.
So now this has to change.
So we're saying this,
deploy the femoral cluster,
and that gives us our k three s,
which shouldn't be a as a promise, so
I should await that.
We then do our k three s server,
which is going to be our k3s.
Server
dot start
with a whole bunch of awaits here too.
And this gives me my service.
We probably don't need the endpoint then just
based on how this is working, but down
here, we can see that we want the
config.
So this returns a file.
This is
a helper function that is reaching into
Wow. It's using it in GraphQL.
Cool. Let's not look at that.
Our service painting here is actually our server
even though I don't think we need the
service painting. Yep. Marcus has already confirmed that
in the chat. Thank you very much.
And he's saying that this doesn't need to
be async, so that's one less.
Wait.
Alright. So we don't need the service binding.
We mount on the KubeConfig.
We can see web environment variable. And I
know I'm going pretty fast here, so maybe
I'll take a minute just to
take questions. The KubeConfig.
And we're saying that our KubeConfig
exists
here.
And then So
actually added a with environment to update the
path to make OU control work
if we wanna add that in too.
Yeah. Well, I I don't think we're going
in we're we're going to need it, but
let's let's wait and see.
Okay.
So here, we should be able to actually
run kube control against our cluster. But I
really wanna see if this works,
which I'm sure it will.
Just yeah. Let's try it.
Welcome.
That's oh, that's the wrong zoom.
So what is it doing now? It's firing
up k three. Oh, there we go. And
all that cool stuff.
Yeah. Just maybe a bit too much info.
Alright. Let's see. What do we get?
So it's saying connection
failed,
but it wrote the KubeConfig,
but wasn't able to speak to the cluster.
It looks like or even before then, you
had a fatal
with k three starting up, it couldn't find
c groups. Do you have c groups v
two enabled on your
system?
I wonder if we need to use this
endpoint function just to force the service
to hang around.
I wonder if this is just being
stripped off
by the DAG.
So we've got far too many awaits here
now. Let's just restart this. K three s
server endpoint
where we want that poor 80
scheme.
This is
promise.
Marcus said it could be a pod manager.
I mean, it very well could be, but
if I need to switch to Docker, that's
that's easy done.
Let's see.
Okay. So it tried to run kubectl get
pods this time.
It failed to open the permissions on that
file. Okay. Let's progress.
So I I I think just calling the
endpoint stops the service from being too early.
But let's confirm that we can cat this,
and I haven't made an arse of that.
Right?
Does your image have cat?
It should.
I mean, I know dogs in there.
I mean, I could probably just do this.
Yeah.
It's it's it's running bash, so that should
work. I'm modifying the function. Permission denied. I
mean, it looks like it was KubeControl that
was unhappy. Not
No. It says open permission denied. KubeControl was
fine.
Well, right. But is that open coming from
KubeControl?
Because that's coming from KubeControl because that's what
would be opening that file unless it's the
because that's coming from inside the container. Right?
Oh, service filter. Yeah. Like
yeah, Marcus thinks it might be a, root
issue.
Are you running rootless?
We couldn't resolve the process cat.
I'm I don't think I am doing Podman.
Okay.
So let's take a look at web trial.
We have these container ops. We can set
the permissions to be very permissive.
Oh, yeah.
So
and we could just do
seven seven seven. What user does your container
run as?
Do you know?
I probably should off the top of my
head, but I'm gonna just let's get inside
of it. That
I know for a fact.
Let's get inside.
Alright. So I've removed any command. We're just
basically provisioning
this container. So now instead of standard out,
let's do terminal, and let's have a wee
poke around.
Next, you'll be telling me there's no shell.
No. There's a shell in there.
I'm not a big fan of
of
Distroless,
to be honest.
Docker file.
It runs
as user
four thirty one.
Alright.
Yep. We are the OpenUnison user,
and our KubeConfig is coming in as root.
So Yeah. There's our issue.
But we do have Kube control.
We definitely well
yeah. I'm not gonna auto complete bash.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
No. There's no OpenUnison control. So
but that's the path problem. Right? So we
don't need to work over that. So if
I do chair mod seven seven oh, I'm
do I have sudo?
No.
Alright. Oh, it's a container, not a VM.
Alright. So how let's have a look at
this web file. So we wanna tweak the
permissions.
Now we could,
it, but we can also set the owner.
So let's do let's try and be semi
good citizens
and set the owner to 431.
Oh, it wants a string. Okay. So, open
Unison.
Now if we run this again to get
back into the terminal, we should be able
to cat that fail at least.
Okay. So you've added that terminal to the
end, and that's what gets you in. Okay.
Cool. Yeah. It's a nice little debugging tool.
Yeah. I know it goes counter to current
security dogma, but I will say that I
think that a container
without
a shell is actually less secure than a
container with a shell.
Oh, those permissions look good.
Almost. Oh, no. Great.
Temp coop. Oh,
it's got the group as four thirty one.
It's got the user. The user's right. It's
just I think that's Right. But if you
look at the group, the group is supposed
to be 433.
Alright. Okay. Well, I'm not I'm not fussed
about the group.
Alright. But if you're on 640
if you've got it on 644
and you've got the group wrong, I think
that might help work.
Yeah. I think the permissions are wrong because
it wants an octal string.
Does it want it's like a string string,
not a number?
Oh, I don't know. The example said zero
six hundred,
which it doesn't even like. So that's
so this
is
okay. What number do we need? So seven
seven seven is octal. What's that in decimal?
Can't believe I'm gonna Google this.
Compare
to decimal
511.
Let's see if that's a bit nicer. And
let's actually see what,
convert,
decimal.
So I was doing 644 to octal.
Let's
see if Google can do it. No.
+1 204.
Right. And, yeah, that may actually add up
to what we were seeing.
So let's try 511 that I save.
Rawkode suggesting
that
there's a JavaScript syntax.
Oh, it does work.
Interesting.
We'll try that next, but let's see if
the decimal approach works.
I'm not even gonna try and cat the
fail. I'm just gonna run cube control yolo
sail.
Kube
config temp to config get pods.
So you have that env in there. You
probably shouldn't even need the dash dash koop
config.
Oh, you're right. Yeah.
So we're in a position there. From here.
But I want to run that container l
s. Yeah. You can't see
yeah. You can't you can't see the service
containers.
Okay.
So now we'll I'll leave that as octal.
The that says decimal did work, so both
are valid options.
But now we need to work out
why it's not quite working. So we can
add our web exec back.
We wanna keep control
get
pods
dash a.
Now I wonder if this is just a
terminal debug thing.
So let's run it as that. Let's see
if we get a list.
Time and a half.
So that IP 1087,
is that
your network,
or is that a pod man network? Is
that a like, what network is that?
We could probably do a console log endpoint.
That's a string. Right? Yeah. And so that'll
tell us what the endpoint for the KCS
service is.
Marcus saying the k trees isn't starting.
Alright.
Let's switch to Docker.
When in doubt
Which may be relatively difficult to do on
my Nexus machine.
So
I'll have open next home.
We want next auth.
Podman.
Yeah. I don't have rootless configured, but either
way, false that
docker
enable
true.
And
I'm gonna fast rebuild, which means I shouldn't
have to reboot.
We also have the kind work from last
week, so I can always just use that
function, drop it straight in, and we'll get
a very similar result.
We work great and kind. The entire
almost the entire book is written on top
of kind. So
Mhmm.
Alright. It's installing Docker, starting the service.
Now curious. What's your base OS? Is it
Ubuntu? Is it Nexus.
Oh, it is Nexus.
It is.
How
do you unalias on fish shell?
Oh, yes.
Trying to fill in Podman. I don't have
Podman anymore.
Alright. We need to make one more change.
This is where my Nexus is coming to
bite me in the ass.
Docker can now just be Docker.
Rawkode is either Podman or Nexus.
Hey. Leave my Nexus out of this.
Alright.
So if I just drop that shell, pop
open a new one,
Docker should be Docker.
Sweet.
Which means we will have to do a
just run Dagger functions. It should start the
new
before we put a new image.
Docker daemon.
No. I can't remember my password.
Hey.
Why is that not working?
I bet it's gonna be permissions now.
I need to add myself
to the Docker group.
Are you shredding some evidence? What was that?
My
my standing desk. Was bringing it down. Figured
I'd
Yeah. Take a load off.
Now I'm confused.
Okay. Sudo works.
Not ideal.
Functions.
So now, unfortunately, we do have to wait
for a new Dagger engine,
and pull down your image again, but it
doesn't take that long. So we'll give that
a wee minute and see what happens.
But I did do this with Podman and
before
for the cargo project.
Cargo.
Hey, Kat. Watching.
We can oh oh, wait. That's a refractor
branch.
Oh, they merged it. Sweet. Okay. It's already
on main.
So if we do need a kind cluster
with pod man
Can you assume that in a while? That's
really tiny text.
You're not allowed to see. Sorry. Trade secrets.
Alright.
So
just in case, we'll do if oh, just
to call this a cluster,
which is a promise
and a service.
And that's the Python code at least. So
let's convert it
where
oh, there's also the create Docker and Docker.
Docker Docker.
That container
from
Docker Dame with exposed port
to three
seven five
with exec.
Property
dash dash host
TCP
two three seven five and
true.
I'm typing as quickly as I can go.
So that gives us a Docker and Docker.
Let's see how we're getting on over here.
Alright. Okay.
Let me make sure we don't bust it
to code to point. Let's comment all this
out and try OpenUnison again just to see
if this was a PodLAN issue, and then
we've got our backup ready to go if
we need to. So sudo
dagger
call
Unison.
Wish I'd made a bigger cup of tea
now. Gonna have to strap in for this
episode.
I hope you're got dinner plans or anything.
No. I just, scarfed down a protein bar.
Sorry. I was on mute. I, scarfed down
a protein bar and made sure that the,
hanger monster didn't come out.
Let's zoom
in on this. Let's see how k three
s is getting on.
Looks like it's just pulling the image.
Oh, that's failing too, Marcus.
Or it's okay now.
Well, that might be okay.
It pop up here.
We can actually see the service one.
So what's happened is the Dagger knows we're
trying to use this as a service. So
it's actually waiting for it to become healthy
before continuing with the job.
And now I think it's pulling your container.
So we may actually be getting somewhere with
the Docker approach.
Oh, I think it worked.
Okay.
It was pod man.
Pod man.
You know, I love the idea of pod
man. It just never seems to
yeah. It it just never seems to work
in the use case I need.
Love the idea of it because I hate
Damon's, but I I I get to
every time I try to switch to it,
it doesn't last.
I'll spend some time debugging that later,
and maybe I can contribute something to the
module.
But just to confirm,
I never saw any standard out, and that's
just because there's no resources.
So let's try to control get namespace.
Right. Okay. We So there was no output
just because there were no resources. I possibly
missed it, but we are able to query
get namespaces,
which means
we don't need to go with the backup
approach. Things are jamming
as they were, which means we can now
deploy our first Helm chart. Now to do
that, we're gonna have to add the repository.
So is that documented
here?
Yeah. So go to the manual.
So go to deploy the authentication portal.
Then over on the right, scroll down the
bottom,
and there's manual deployment.
Alright. So we're gonna create an airspace.
I'll do the repository ad first and the
repo update.
I'm gonna do this all in line just
now to get some progress on the road,
and then we'll look at how we can
refactor this code to be nicer because
because we're building pipelines as code with Dagger,
we can actually treat the code to enter
everything as code, which is sounds so silly
to say it. Right? Treating code as code,
but it is super important for actually just
building stuff that can be composed and scaled
and be
actually be enjoyable to write.
So so we're adding the repository.
We'll run the Helm repository update,
and then we're going to deploy the first
one.
Now I can just tell Helm to create
that namespace,
but, of course, we
I have Helm do it when we can
do it.
So even before you call the Helm chart,
though, we need a
Helm file.
We need a values file and pass it.
Now the operator won't matter because everything's default,
so that's okay.
Okay.
So I guess so okay. So you wanna
do the first chart first?
Will it be successful with no values?
Yeah. It'll that one will be successful without
any values. Okay. So do you is there
an example values file that we're gonna need?
Yeah. So if you go to the top
of this
if you go to the top, you click
on prerequisites,
scroll down a little bit. We can skip
past the dashboard. So see where it says
site specific
and then using OU control or manual, there's
a download default values.
So that's that's what we'll customize.
Okay. What are we do know what we're
customizing?
So the the the short version is
those first three options, OpenUnison host, dashboard host,
and API server host. Mhmm. Those are going
to be where it says apps.0u.
Tremolo.dev.
Mhmm. That's gonna be the IP address.
So in a in a production rollout, that
would be the host the
host names that you'd use for these apps,
which would resolve to the IP address of
your load balancer for your ingress controller.
So since you don't I don't think you
have a DNS setup, I use nip I
0 for quick testing.
Okay. So I'm gonna
do interface,
open Unison
config,
which has a network,
which is a object,
and then as an open
Unison host,
which is a string
dashboard
host, which is a string,
and API server
as a string. So now we have a
type for that values
file.
I'll just comment this out.
So we can create a
types
TypeScript variable
with this
shape
and write functions to this to the point
where we can say, you know, const
get open Unison
config
as a function
which needs the IP address. So we'll say
IP address,
which is a string,
and it returns
an OpenUnison
config sales thing.
Like so.
What have I got wrong there? Oh, because
it because it because this comes after.
No.
Oh, it's just so we have to return
a value. Yeah.
So we could we could say return,
and
we got network. See, I love this all
complete. This is why I'm in this game.
This is why I love
doing everything as code.
Alright.
And then we actually
can just literally JSON stringify that or YAML
stringify it when we mount it into the
container. But what we want to do is
make sure that we're using NIP.
Now I don't remember the exact syntax for
NIP, but it's like IP address, and you
have to replace the dots
with a You don't have to replace the
dots. I mean, I do that, but you
don't have to. Alright. Okay. So we can
just say IPaddress.net.io?
Well, you gotta you wanna put a host
name in front of it. So, like, API
server would be, like, API.
IP address.
Oh, right. Okay. On the other side of
it.
Oh, yeah. Because the yeah. Alright. So you
want it to be, like, API. API.
Exactly.
And then, you know, like, dashboard.
They gotta be three separate host names.
That's alright. We can do that. And all
you
Yep. You happy?
Looks good to me.
Okay.
So we create the namespace.
Let's mount our file. So we'll see
web file, anonymous,
mounted file.
We wanna mount it to I'm just gonna
call this helmvalues.YAML.
And here,
we have to provide the source.
I don't think that can be just a
string.
Well, when you wanna get to Maybe I
can do that. Maybe it was web file
I want, and that allows me just to
see.
Let's check. I'll work this out. So are
you are you grabbing the the file that
we have on the doc site?
Well, no. Because the diff there that's the
defaults. Right?
Well, it it's
sorta.
We actually don't
we we use the default
values
because
we try and maintain backwards compatibility.
And so we've got customers
that run older versions of the charts.
So we we tend not to force you
to use the default. We don't rely on
the default values.
We we say start with this and then
customize it because it's going across multiple charts.
So, really, what you wanna do is either
pull that in
and custom and update
you know, what I generally do is I
pull that in.
I up I convert it to JSON.
I make the updates to the JSON, and
then I output it as YAML.
Does that make sense?
Okay. We'll we'll work it out.
I'm trying to remember how I get a
file, Marcos.
You got an assist there?
Creating a file from a string. I remember
it's possible.
Let's check the docs.
File.
There is a way.
Maybe I just need to write it to
a local file and fill in
with new file. Thank you, Marcus.
I just could
not for the life of me get that.
Okay.
And that just wants a string. Right?
Yeah. String contents. Sweet.
So that is going to be our helm
values,
and then
we need to convert that to
YAML.
What have we got? Where is it? Package
JSON.
Yeah.
MPM.
Oh,
I don't need to do it.
Dagger will do it.
Or will it need the node modules? I
guess we're gonna find out.
Node. Js
struct or object.
Marcus will be out at the screen now
going, you should just have done a fail.
Why are you doing a fancy interface?
Alright.
GS YAML.
Cool.
No. I don't need to do a new
one to solve so I can get the
completion,
or I could just copy an example.
You know, it'll do
YAML dot dump, I'm assuming.
Yeah. Okay.
So
YAML
dot dump,
and that's going to be our helm values.
And the import is
GS YAML.
Cool.
So let's just make sure that works
by using our terminal trick.
Yeah.
Marikos is smiling.
That's not a happy smile.
But I do think there's value. Honestly,
this is just like, being able to do
something like that is what makes me happy
with doing things as code and then building
functions and then sharing them and all being
composable and publishable to NPM or whatever. Like,
that to me just makes things fun. Plus,
you know what? I can test this now.
We can write a function to put in
wrong host names and stuff and build test
against it. There's just so much power in
this as code approach.
Well, yeah. I mean, that that's one of
the reasons why we built OU Control in
the first place was
most of the the issues that were being
opened up about OpenUnison
installed
were either
confusion about what the host names were supposed
to be
or,
like, missing certificates.
And so one of the things we were
doing we were doing, like, OU Control
is make sure that you don't have all
don't have any of those host names get
repeated because people were trying to jam in
the same host name to all three. I
was like, no. They gotta be different. So
just having
a way
beyond just a template to be able to
say,
hey. Here's some business logic. That's huge.
How can I just get the IP address?
The host name,
which returns a promise.
And Marcos all code is real code.
Whatever.
Const host name equals
await k three s server
host name.
Yeah. Sure. Sure.
Yeah. I can't use the endpoint because I'd
have to, like, regex out the the port
number and stuff. The host name should just
return what I expect,
but we will confirm that. This gives me
an object which now can be dumped.
So
we should be looking a bit better
with this
as real code. I mean,
I I misheard what you were saying there,
Mark. He's he's slagging my code and saying
it's not real code, but it is real
code. Ah, okay.
Means contrived. Not contrived because we're solving a
real problem today, but, you know, we're we're
trying to move fast.
Alright. With a break. We're breaking things.
I'm always breaking things.
Invalid selection for terminal.
Oh, it's saying no function deploy.
Function deploy.
Not complete.
K. What did I get wrong in my
code?
Oh, wait. Expect isn't equals. Oh, okay. It's
because I changed that from an interface dot
type.
Because I thought that was the first error
was and then realized that we weren't actually
setting helm values to anything. So
good thing I'm paying attention.
How are you enjoying the TypeScript, Mark, being
a Java developer?
You know, I've never actually used I use
a lot of JavaScript. I've never used TypeScript.
I like it.
It's
I like the that's the one thing that
drives me nuts about JavaScript is the lack
of typing.
Yeah. TypeScript is pretty sweet.
Alright. Look at that.
I think we're cooking.
We're getting there. Although those are those host
names aren't gonna work, I don't think. Yeah.
That's it. Oh. Yeah. Because if you send
that to that IO, I don't think that
that's gonna work. You need the API. Yeah.
So we do need to use
I mean, we could always resolve it,
But it would be nice just to get
the IP address.
Is there a DNS function in,
excuse me, in Dagger?
Guess it won't be DNS, though.
Right?
Well, there is DNS. Right? Like, if I
run this again
Right. But isn't that hostname mounted that hostname
is probably mounted in your Docker container
as a,
Etsy host. It's not Yeah.
But, I mean, we can still resolve that
by running,
let's see. Peter is here. Right? Well, we
grab this
and
ping.
It still resolves.
I don't have any commands to run. No.
What what have you left me?
Try just curl. It'll
at least give me an IP address even
if it doesn't work.
Oh, and then it's
well, you said there was NGINX in there.
That
actually should work. Right?
Let me think. Let me think.
Okay. So we got an IP address
and our KubeConfig.
Now this is gonna be horrible.
Mean, horrible. Parse it out of there?
Yeah. Totally. Unless Marcos could tell me how
to get an IP address from this endpoint.
I mean, is endpoint gonna be the IP,
or is that gonna be the host name
too? Let's let's check that first, right, before
I go doing some really bad, bad, bad,
bad things.
You did a bad, bad thing?
Let's see what the endpoint is because maybe
that's gonna be a lot easier to parse
than me rejecting
the KubeConfig.
But I'm sure we could speak to the
Dagger team and just get a
an IP address from this.
No. The endpoint also appears to be.
Alright.
So we need to do this from the
KubeConfig.
So
we can't do this yet
because we need to be
here.
We can kinda just say that's fine,
But now we need to run a command
inside this container. So we're gonna get IP
address,
which is equal.
Instead of returning this, we're gonna assign it.
So this is our
setup
Helm container.
Horrible name. Horrible, horrible name.
Mhmm. So we could do we
could do another web exec where we're going
to do a cat
on
temp
Kube
config. Now I could probably actually have just
a
can we get it from Kube control?
Can you run Kube control?
Yeah. You can. Right?
K. Get notes.
Do you have VPN? No. Not on my
VPN.
I'm just gonna parse it. So
and then we can do a setup Helm
cluster, web new file, Helm values. So now
we need our Helm values here, and it's
actually going to be,
I think that's in a way to get
string
and IP address,
and we're gonna try and capture.
Substring.
Nope.
Fained.
Can't remember I had to regex.
Search.
Can I do regex?
Nope.
Let's Google it.
JS
regex extract
from string.
Undo.
Okay. So what we want to get is
scroll up.
We start that cat output. Yes. We want
this.
But we're regexing for this.
Well, it's server
colon
space
http
s
capture group.
We can just do dot star because we
have a deterministic end, which a colon six
four four three.
We can then see that our IP address
is 1
Are there any functions on that to make
sure I'm getting the right capture?
No.
Okay.
K. Config.
And here,
So I need to make sure that's gonna
be a string.
So this is returning.
I need to work it. I should close
that tab too quickly. It's in there.
Where do you want?
Let's return this.
Yeah. Marcos is right. It should be the
load balancer IP, not the
oh, wait a minute.
This is so much easier than we're making
it.
Oh, help me.
Yeah. Because get service
and Ingress
NGINX.
Right?
So the service is gonna be your Ingress
NGINX controller.
And then
you're going to pipe that into
you're gonna do dash o
JSON.
Pipe that into j q dash r,
and you're gonna want
dot
spec
oh, because this particular service doesn't actually have
a load balancer IP.
Export config.
That's temp. KOU.
Oh, yeah. That's the one.
I'll get to this cluster.
Ah, who makes me use MFA for everything?
Oh, right. Never mind.
Okay.
K. Get service.
Ingress.
Internet.
K namespace.
Yeah. The Service.
This is the end this is the end
cluster address. Right? That's not the one we
want.
No. You want the load balancer.
No. The way I'm doing it is right.
We don't need the load balancer because we're
if kube control is working, that's the IP
address that we want. Right. But the IP
address
is gonna go to the load balancer
for
the NGINX.
So if there's a different interface that NGINX
is listening on
because that's what Marcos is saying is
I'm gonna keep going. I I think I'm
right.
I'm not seeing I'm gonna keep going.
That way
that way we got it in our back
pocket. How about that?
20.
So y
0.
That return to string. That's
base
dot spec.
Alright. Let's see what we get with that.
Status? Oh, I see.
I think Marikos is tapped out. He's like,
fuck these guys.
There we go.
Two j q dash r dot status.
Dot
ingress.
No.
Or no. Got lot of balance. Rejects didn't
match.
No. What what?
Oh, it's a camel case.
Shouldn't have charged it my version. I'm super
awesome at typing, by the way. I just
wanna point that out.
Type for a living, and I never figured
out how to touch type.
Boom. Okay. My Regex is good.
Group one.
I'm gonna give you this just as a
fallback if
you need it
because this gets me
it directly from
who we need rather than having a process.
Pull up a REPL.
Excel.
Js.
Yeah. Marcus is saying you need the external
IP.
No.
Oh, wait. I'm passing in the wrong oh
my god.
I hate myself.
Wanna hit yourself? That's what we're here for.
I mean, if I do it right,
let's say that,
Rx.exec
and pass in the rate value.
That's an error. There you go.
Then
in fact, I should have seen that. Const
a equals and then a
zero.
Oh.
I should be able
a one.
But I can see it here.
Wonder if the Rx just gets blown away.
Right.
So
far a b c equals r x dot
ex exec
with our server value.
Yeah. Okay. We're good.
Okay.
Let's get back in that computer now.
This is gonna work.
Shouldn't be getting too cocky, should I?
Load container from my okay. That's just my
Dagger code being wrong.
Container.
That worked.
We have weighted that, so that's fine.
Helm value should be okay.
And we can just debug that if we
need to.
Oh, I'm not returning.
There we go.
So this is going to get me my
terminal.
And
Oh, it's close.
There we go.
Wrong index.
Okay. I think that's fine. So let's
let's try it. Right? So what do we
want to do now? We want to do
a Helm deploy.
Right. So
we're gonna do
you look at the docs.
OpenUser.
The docs seem like so long ago.
I know.
Alright. So Oh, yeah. I'll send you manual.
Portal. Manual deployment.
So it's gonna be helm install.
Yep. Except we're gonna add two parameters to
it.
And I've gotta remember what they are off
the top of my head. Home install.
Dash f
temp helm eyes.
We're gonna do helm install.
Like that. Right? Wait. That's what we're gonna
do. Okay. So we're gonna do dash dash
wait and dash dash wait for jobs.
Yeah. Okay. Because we're doing this
with that. So it won't really matter for
this one, but for consistency's sake, I think
we should
Yeah. And we could actually just wrap this
helm install into a function and make them
Yeah. Happen all the time. Right? But let's
I wanna see us get something
running. I wanna see OpenUnison,
the operator running in this cluster. That will
make me happy.
So now this is starting a new k
threes with each one. Right?
It is indeed.
We're now waiting.
So the helm install is running.
Feeling pretty confident.
Oh, no. No. No. Is there something in
the two e to let you watch the
alpha
or again? Sorry? Did you mess something up?
No. I thought this o u was an
error, but I actually just called Oh. I
actually called it that. So it's it's fine.
Oh, so, like, did we now I'm a
little confused. Did we generate a new
file just based on the the couple configs
you made, or did you pull in
Well, there's the operator.
Yay.
Smashed it.
So can I see the gallery smile?
Yeah. I'm just curious.
Helm.
Okay. So
but we're gonna need so what I was
saying before is we've gotta take this
and merge it with that default values file
from the website,
from the documentation.
But if that's the defaults, that will just
be merged with the defaults.
So
that is not so the the one that
we have that we ask you to download
and start with is actually not
the default values
from inside the chart. Gotcha. Because it caused
us heartburn to go with that route.
Alright. So let's do this then.
I'm gonna copy everything,
but remove our stuff Yeah. Yeah. Just so
I can cheat and make this easy.
Okay. I don't wanna I don't wanna build
this this I don't wanna generate a massive
TypeScript interface from all of that. Right. I
want you to do it to show off
a little bit. So what we're gonna do
here is const default
values
equals
tag dot with.
Oh, wait. I need to do that on
a container.
Let's go up here.
Dot with
dot with. Well so can you is there
a function where you can
pull that file in
and then just update
it?
Like, pull it in, parse it as JSON,
then make the update,
and then spit that out as
YAML.
So that way you still have your tight
little interface because you're only customizing a couple
of pieces. You don't need to
Yeah. I'm just gonna mount this straight in
as default and then add two f's to
our helm. I know this is horrible. I
could read this from a disk. I could
use f s dot read file sync. Okay.
I see what you're saying. I just wanna
get this I just wanna get this rocking.
So Yeah.
So default values.
So now we're applying the default values and
then ours over the top with the customizations
for the hosts. So Wait a minute. You're
you do you can do two dash f's?
Yeah.
I never knew that. I learned something new
today. Well, I learned a lot of new
things today. I I never tried that without
it. I'm
99.9%
sure you can do as many dash f's
as you want.
Yeah. Can specify multiple.
Alright.
So we've got That's gonna be pretty cool
if that works.
We we've got three of these to do.
Right? So we've done the operator. Yep.
Let's go back to the docs. So we've
got the manual
process at the bottom.
We've done
so now we're doing orchestra. Right?
Yep. Okay. So even before you do that,
go back to your values dot YAML, the
the big mess that you created, not the
tight little interface.
Alright. So we're gonna add
I gotta look this one up for you
because
the this is the part I don't have
documented.
If I can figure out where the hell.
Okay. Here we go. Onboard v cluster. So
I need to
go to
no. I don't want the help in. I
want OpenUnison
deploy,
and then you need to have a value.
Enable wait for a job. Alright. So you're
gonna add
top level in that particular
Mhmm.
It's gonna be
OpenUnison.
Job is
true.
So it's gonna be top level in the
nope. It'll be a top level.
Don't even bother with this. Just go back
to the big ugly one.
No.
I mean, I guess you could do it
this way too.
Yeah.
I mean, it's just it's just this would
be more of a constant. You're not gonna
because you're running it from an IAC tool,
you're always gonna
I know. But this is but you could
do that too. Yeah. Okay. So our helm
install now changes. The second one is to
install
Orchestra.
Yep.
And everything else is the same. Right? Yeah.
Alright. What's next?
And then we're gonna do orchestra login portal.
K.
And then We got one more. We we
don't list it here, but it's called
medical.
Had the code open.
It is called
I'm digging through my here.
No. That's cluster management. We don't want cluster
management.
Orchestra
dash cube dash o I d c dash
proxy.
Alright.
Oh, I'm excited.
Me too, man.
So now is there something that you can
do in the two e to let us
watch the
standard outlooks
of the container while it's
daggering,
while it's while it's running.
Yeah. Just in the right, and then we'll
get a bit of everything.
Alright. We're helming.
We're helming. We're helming. We're helming. We're helming.
Now we don't actually have an authentication
mechanism set up.
So So can you just tell us all
really work, but you should be able to
get to that
that
the test
of
checking the OIDC issuer.
That part should work. All I really want
us to be able to do is to
deploy it, which I think we've just done,
and then be able to curl against an
API endpoint and then confirm about it. Right?
You know? In fact, even where we are
right now, if all these helms work and
we've deployed OpenUnison,
everything after that is child's play because you're
just basically saying, okay. Let's pull another image.
Maybe it's, like, HTTP pie or maybe it's
HARL dot dev. Or throw in requests to
the API server or we're just doing those
assertions. Are we getting a HTTP 200? Are
we getting,
you know, the
right OIDC configured authentication methods, whatever? At at
that point, it's it's all on you, and
I'm I'm seeing you're the audience here. Right?
Hopefully, what people have seen today is how
this code is a little gnarly. Right? We
could maybe spend five minutes to tidy this
up. But
what we're doing
is cool. Like,
this is cool. We're then take able to
take our helm value and type it. Now
we can use VITEST, VITEST, whatever it's called,
and we can do a whole bunch of
different comparisons
based on our values file.
We can encapsulate a lot of this helm
logic into a single function so that we're
not repeating this over and over because the
only thing changing
is what is the chart and what is
the name of the release.
That is it. So we can we can
quantify all of that. We're in a a
really nice position. Plus,
I mean, I wish we didn't have to
do this,
but we've now seen that we could reach
into these service containers or or the other
containers and
extrapolate information
to then propagate that down into other steps.
So there's a lot of really cool things
happening here, and we got an error.
But it's your chart, I'm gonna say.
Orchestra failed.
Don't
care about that.
Pod test orchestra.
Oh,
so we actually do need to have some
kind of authentication mechanism
or the testing pod will fail.
So if you look at your config
let's just make our lives easy Mhmm. Even
though it won't work. So
we've got see where it says SAML IDP
underscore URL?
It's commented line one fifty one and one
fifty two. Yep. Just uncomment those for now.
I'll get you past that.
Yeah. Because we build error checking in where
we can.
How rude.
It really is, isn't it? We should talk
to somebody about that.
Alright. I mean, even if we take out
the orchestra deployment, I'm not that fast. We're
still in a position where we've deployed a
collection of helm charts. We've taken advantage of
Type Script. We're using Dagger.
We're using lots of parts of Dagger right
now to show how this works. Like, I'm
Well and, like, in a real world scenario
so we're we're deploying OpenUnison in its simplest
use case here as a login port.
But what I find really interesting here is
that
let's take this to the namespace as a
service
example.
You can build a lot of custom logic
into OpenUnison.
So, like, I've got customers
where
the
you know, where there's logic in there to,
like, integrate,
you know, integrate
charge codes into namespace creation to do chargeback
and and and look back and, you know,
checking resource constraints
to figure out if the quota,
you know, meets some kind of line where
a manual pro. Like, being able to automate
that
testing from those more complex scenarios
where you're just calling our API. That's a
really cool use case to me that, you
know, we're not really doing yet,
but we could.
Yeah. You know, we've broken on this Kubernetes
landscape a while. And when it comes to
test and Helm charts, the status quo right
now
is pretty much just to template it out
and run
against it, right, and do assertions against the
the generated Kubernetes manifest. There's not a lot
that actually happens in cluster.
We were in closer.
New container.
Yeah. Orchestra. I'm gonna remove Orchestra.
Well, if you remove Orchestra, you won't have
anything.
Oh, we have the operator. I mean, we've
shown
some stuff.
And we guess that we'll do assertions against
the operator. So let's just do that.
Yeah. So the status quo for helm testing
right now is really just to generate that
YAML, which means you lose access to hooks
and jobs and all the stuff that they're
doing in cluster.
I've not seen a lot of people, if
any, actually, I've not seen anyone
deploy to, like, a kind and build assertions
against that. I'm sure some people are doing
it, but I I would argue that this
as code approach allows you to go a
lot deeper and a lot more automation than
what has previously been possible. Oh, yeah. I
mean, like, I'm looking at so the way
we automate our testing is we've got a
QA cluster
that,
you know,
we we use Git to do the we
use GitOps and Argo to do it. But,
you know, we wanna get into the habit
of having
these automated tests
and to be able to say, okay.
I wanna run this
I wanna run this against the cluster that
has NGINX. I wanna run this against the
cluster that has Istio.
I wanna go through the same type of
steps
every time. So,
you know, I like the the fact that
I can spin up a k three's cluster,
and he'll talk to it as one option.
But then I can also see saying, you
know what? I'm gonna mount in,
you know, a virtual cluster that's got my
baseline in it already. So I I like
that there's that flexibility in there and that
it's code.
Yeah. Alright. Let's do It's not code I
have to recompile every twenty five minutes.
Let's
make this nicer. Right? And this will be
the last thing we do. I know we've
went way over the time that we set
aside for this. So I I really am
sorry, but I hope you're enjoying.
Let's write a function. It's just called deploy
helm
chart.
This needs a char release name,
chart name,
and
values,
which is just an object. Any any JavaScript
object can be serialized.
So
this is going to return
a promise
container because we probably wanna work with whatever
we get back,
and then the function itself can be blah.
Right? So let's do that.
Oh, we need to provide a
yeah. Let's provide the container.
We we could actually build up our own
with Helm and use your image,
but then we did the KubeConfig and stuff.
So just to make that a little bit
easier, we're just gonna say that we're gonna
pass in the container.
So now we're gonna say container,
and that's just that code that we have.
Only we're gonna do some interpolation,
which is that here, we want the release
name,
the chart name,
and we could add properties for namespace, for
wait for jobs. In fact, let's even do
that. Right? Because we don't need to wait
for jobs all the time. And we're now
at a point where this should actually be
a structure. So let's call
this ops,
helm ops.
I'm gonna hate myself for making this more
complex than I should for the last five
minutes. However,
wait for jobs. We're programmers. Making it more
complex is our job. And
wait. So there's two different ways. So let's
take that.
So
if we have ops
dot wait,
we do
wait.
Otherwise, nothing.
Opt dot wait for jobs.
Nothing.
That'll do.
And we return back our container.
Oh, no. I just I've not made this
async. So
cool.
This now means that this becomes
and we can't use the fluent interface anymore
because it's not attached to a container.
Const c equals
look at type.
And we can do,
what did I call it, Helm? No.
Employ Helm chart,
which takes a c, which takes a release,
which takes a chart name.
Operator.
So it takes our values.
We've mounted them into the container already.
So I was gonna make that an object
and actually do that. So let's come back
to that in a second. And then the
ops,
let me see. Wait. True. Wait for jobs.
True.
Let me make this something that we can
write over.
So this disappears.
So we're gonna pass in
our helm values.
Can I not redeclare
even if I make out of what?
This isn't let redeclare or what does it
declare?
I mean, maybe I should be doing var.
Right? Anyway, let's do it this way. So
this now becomes no longer needed because we're
going to do this
and laying down here
with our values object.
So
with new fail,
Temp
values
dot YAML.
And that is our YAML dot dump
and values.
So not the best refactoring,
but really trying not to push us onto
that two hour mark for the stream.
But you can see how
this is a simple function that just makes
this a lot easier. Yep.
I don't need to see one. We actually
just want whatever
it was called above.
Yeah.
Oh, set up helm container.
This now becomes a lot easier for us
to then chain that together
and say, okay. We need to deploy another
chart.
We can't do it because we didn't create
a class. There are ways we could have
made this fluent still.
Let's see. We can now deploy as many
charts as we want and we've defined what
that interface looks like. And I think I
just think, again, treating this stuff as code
enables so many different things. We could build
classes where these are helper functions and give
us our fluent API to continue this because
our base layer is going to be a
certain position, which is to open Unison container
in this approach. And and now we can
test this as well, and we can test
the end to end product based on everything
that we've done.
I'm calling a quest there because that is
that's been an absolute monster session. Let's pop
back over here.
But I think we learned a lot. Right?
Like, the, you know, the goal wasn't to
learn about OpenUnison.
The goal was to learn about, you know,
how do we take Dagger
and do something really cool with it? And
I think we accomplished the really cool,
like,
being able to say launch a, you know,
launch a cluster, a k three's cluster,
integrate with it,
right, pull in multiple configs in a reusable
way.
Yep.
And test it all out. I mean, that
that's,
you know,
that's pretty cool. Like, that ranks pretty high
on my pretty cool meter.
That's nice.
Nice.
Alright. Well, I will continue to work on
this off stream and put together some real
assertions. What I will do is I will
comment on this video on YouTube,
this time next week, hopefully, or earlier,
with a link to the code and the
actual build in the test cases. I'll probably
use hurl dot dev or something like that.
It's a really cool text based tool for
making HTTP requests and assertions.
And,
yeah, hopefully, we can get this pushed towards
OpenUnison Helm charts repository as some fun test
cases to do. Yeah. Absolutely.
Thank you so much, Mark, for joining me
today and for kinda guiding me on the
OpenUnison parts. I hope Dagger has piqued your
interest and that you're gonna
venture further into the Daggerverse
literally unfigured.
Absolutely.
Alright.
Thank you to everyone who stuck with us
throughout that. I know that was a very
long session. I hope you found it useful.
Let us know in the comments, and, feel
free to say thank you or you suck
in the comment box as we say goodbye
for today. But, Mark, thank you again. I
will speak to you soon. And to everyone
else, have a wonderful week.
Bye. Adios.
Build castles for ones and zeros. We stood
tall like coheroes.
For every bug squashed another plan in this
academy.
You took this stand.
Next time, we'll be cheering for you.
I'll be cheering for you.
Oh,
for you.